[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants vous savez nous
venons de faire un très long voyage
nous avons visité de nombreux pays et
avons fait la connaissance de beaucoup
de petits enfants qui mangent bien leur
soupe et qui vont se coucher bien
sagement chaque soir n'est ce pas nous
howie ce qu'ils étaient gentils ces
petits il s'endormait fit une toute
petite poignée de sable ils dorment
heures mais je préfère quand même
nicolas et pimprenelle j'ai hâte de les
retrouver
pas trop moi aussi mon bon nounours ah
l'on descend vite les voir et en
bracelet bien fort de ma part mon le
schmoll et hop hop hop hop hop on
compose mon concours ou bonsoir la
petite famille bonsoir ma parole de son
trajet
ils sont sûrement touché mais non ils ne
sont pas dans leur lit
oui nous les coca ils se sont cachés
sous l'ordre à 20,5 en voyage au soir
petits garnements
c'est comme ça que vous me faites vomir
chaque soir pendant son absence
et on l'a fait j'ai bien nagé massot et
je me suis lâché mes coups et j'ai pu
cette colère et j'ai fait bien et moi
aussi bien bien bien que l'enfant rien
n'annonce regarde sur la mer qu'est ce
que c'est où mon porteront camaguey que
je suis bon grand-père était aussi très
gentil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur 90 et bien bon à vous tous les
petits garçons à grecs les plus petites
il y aussi nounours tu es gentil d'une
autre en syrie vous me faites un gros
plaisir
alors je vais vous dire
voilà c'est simple tout bonnement
j'adore
mon mouton à lui ni moi nous nous quand
tu reviens bientôt j'espère bien ah oui
nous nous vous seriez je donnerai ma
bonne nuit le vent là j'ai tout fait
pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonne nuit petit nicolas bonne nuit
petit pas pr neil bonne nuit tous les
petits enfants embrasser bien fort beau
papa et maman est allée vite vous
couchez bien sagement comme nos deux
petits amis à te voilà nounours on ne va
pas trop oui mon gros nounours en route
bonne nuit les enfants à demain bolden
enfin pour
[Musique]